opération rassemblement ce vendredi à
versailles
luc chatel était l'invité d'honneur
d'une réunion publique organisée en
soutien à françois fillon il est venu
défendre le programme du candidat à la
présidentielle je vais parler de fondre
nos électeurs veulent qu'on parle du
fond
nos électeurs veulent qu'on leur montre
les solutions pour sortir d'asile besson
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui voilà les
socialistes on a fait c'est le pays
économiquement donc notre devoir c'est
de venir ici défendre notre candidat
défendre nos idées pour réformer en
profondeur ce pays malgré les soupçons
d'emplois fictifs qui pèsent sur sa
femme et ses enfants
les sympathisants républicains restent
mobilisés selon une enquête ifop publiée
ce week end
70% d'entre eux veulent que françois
fillon maintienne sa candidature
on peut dire l'objectif est atteint
puisque on avait 450 personnes ce soir
on avait la plupart des parlementaires
soient des sénateurs les députés qui
étaient là le président du sénat gérard
larcher le président du conseil
départemental permet d'y et donc oui
c'était indispensable de tous nous
réunir dans cette période on va dire un
peu de turbulences
fillon a fait largement ses preuves
1 c'est un homme qui est montée
progressivement qui a pris qui a fini
premier ministre en un moment qui a
résolu une crise mondiale avec sarkozy
messieurs vous dire qu'on a confiance et
qu'on se moque de cette petite histoire
ridicule qui a été mais surmédiatisé
préparer machiavéliquement ne vous
laissez pas confisqué cette élection
mais reste à convaincre l'ensemble des
électeurs selon le même sondage ifop 65%
des français souhaitent que françois
fillon se retire
[Applaudissements]